all right so I just logged in into our own designer Weebly account just because
we want the website to be in our own we're going to create a website for
Queens Creek Arizona concrete now concrete is pretty general make sure
you're talking obviously to your client like some concrete companies they do
driveway patios they do crack repairs they do concrete paving they do stamp
concrete so make sure and this it goes back to your keyword list that you are
targeting only the services that the company does because certain companies
do certain things and not everything so once you're logged in you're probably
not going to have any of these because these are all of our old websites so
you're going to click up here top right create website and okay so here you're
going to pick your theme this is kind of up to you I'm going to pick one of the
ones that we usually use and keep in mind that once you create one frame you
can actually duplicate your website so let's say you have a second concrete
company you can actually just duplicate your first one so you don't have to do
this whole thing from the very start but I am going to show you on how to get it
started for the first time so let's go with this one right here okay and we be
likes to kind of create a website for you but we're going to delete every page
that they made for you except for the home one so you're going to click start
editing right here and it should bring you down here reload editor okay so
you're going to delete that one can stay there for a second you're going to click
on pages up here and I just want to get rid of everything that we've created
for me because we're not going to need it so click on delete confirm let's
delete every page that they made for you because we want to create our own and in
the home one just click on SEO settings make sure there's nothing here okay go
back now we're going to delete everything so every element that was put
in here we want to delete because we're trying to make our own you might just be
able to click here perfect and delete the whole section that way you don't
have to delete every single piece manually so just click delete it should
just eliminate the whole thing okay and then do it again and delete perfect so
pretty fast pretty easy now click on build up here let's add a title up here
in the header section and then we are going to add okay so add so we're going
to click down here on installed apps click on the plus sign where it says add
app and we're going to add some elements are not into designer Weebly already so
in the search bar just type h1 and we're going to add this one right here h1 tag
okay should be free so you don't have to pay for it click on it then click on
add connect and done perfect and now it should show up here okay so we can add
that right here at the bottom okay perfect now we are going to add another
title under our title right here okay so in this top title in the header we're
going to put the company's name obviously we're not going to put the
actual company's name we're just putting the service that we're targeting and
the location so in our case it's going to be and I like to put everything in
capital letters Queens Creek oops concrete okay I don't like going into
separate sentences I like to be in the same line so I'm going to make it
smaller and then we can go back and edit the fonts because they look a little
cartoonish and then we're going to add a phone number right now we don't have a
phone number so you can just put like xxx just so you know that's where you're
going to put the phone number okay all right now we're going to put some text
at the bottom of the h1 I like to put a little spacer there this is up to you on
how you want to structure it you can put a spacer you can put a divider the
divider is just a line so it's right here and then under there right here so
what we like to do is have the h1 right here a text here we like to put a corner
image right here so drag the image until you see this little shape see how the
shape is gone and now the shape is back it looks like a square when you see that
square you just drop it the mouse and once you we put an image right here now
right now it looks a little funky but once you put the image right here you
are going to have the text right next to it and now we're going to put the quote
form the instant quote form right to your right of your text so right here
it's called a contact form on Weebly so we're just going to hold in grab it and
drop it right here perfect this is how we want it to look like and now we're
going to create the quote form and we usually put free a hundred percent
something again we're not making this website to make them look amazing and
fancy we just want them to convert so we wanted them to be simple clear to the
point of what people are getting and how to reach the contractor in the
easiest and fastest way as possible so free a hundred percent instant quote
because we want them to think that they're going to get the quote right away
okay I actually like to put this making myself so I'm going to delete that and
we don't need a comment section so let's just leave the email put a large text
box above the email this is no let's do a short short text box okay perfect and
you're going to click on it right here in the fill title you're going to put
name okay and then we are going to put checkboxes will we arrange the order
just put that and then we're going to put a drop-down box and then do not
forget this we need the phone number because if we don't then our client
cannot call the lead back so make sure the name phone number and the email
right there one important thing this should be automatically done by Weebly
but make sure there is a little asterisk it's red and tiny at the top quarter that
means that the person that is filling out the quote is required to fill out
that information in order to submit the quote if you don't do that then people
can't skip on the number and how you check it is actually right here once you
click on the field it's required is checked out see if I unmark it the
asterisk goes away so make sure that's on because we don't want anyone skipping
on any information because if someone fills this out and we don't have any
more phone number it's a lost lead so and how we like to order this is
actually to put what the client needs at the top and then gathers information at
the bottom because people are more likely to fill it out if they can fill
out their needs first and then tell you who they are instead of the other way
around okay so we're going to change this field to what service do you need
and again you can customize this to whatever your niche is to whatever you
think would be best option items right here you can add as many as you want so
I like to put the services that the client offers so in this case it could
be concrete driveway oops driveway concrete patio these are just some
samples we can put stamped concrete okay and if you click add option you can add
as many as you like if you click on edit you can actually delete them and you can
also move them so you can have stamp concrete at the second and stuff like
that and then you click on done click out of it and you're done with that this
one I like to put when do you need do you need it question mark option items
I'm going to put I am flexible this week and then as soon as possible okay so we
are done making the form and there is something else that we like to add but
make sure you check in with the client and make sure that that's something
that they could possibly offer so first of all we like to center this since
it's the title so center it right there then you're going to add a spacer so
it's not so cramped and then we usually like to add a text right under the free
instant quote where we say something like plus free bonus coupon just to kind
of get them more interested again checking with the client and see if they
could even offer a slight coupon or something like that if they don't then
just remove that and we're going to center that let's make that bold as well
see it and then lastly the button right here see how it's skirted to the left we
want to make a center as well so just click on the main thing you're going to
click on button you're going to align it to the center and we're actually going
to change what it says I like I would like to say get quote exclamation point
then click out of it then oops I don't know why I did that it's not a problem
just move them back how they wear
okay perfect and then one last thing when if you click on form options you can
actually name this and what we like to name it just to keep it organized it
would be the same as the title of the website in our case it's Queen Creek put
the state concrete and then since this is the form for the home page I like to
put in parentheses I like to put an H you can also put home whatever you are
more comfortable with something like that and then right here is where you're
going to put the email you want this form sent to you so I'm just gonna put
my email I wait every time I get this form so I get forwarded to mine okay
then click save and we're done with the form creation okay now I would like to
put more sections because especially on the home page we're going to add a lot
of content so go right here under structure you're going to select section
and you're going to drag it right below right here I like to put a couple of
section because this is the very first one let's put a second one okay and then
we're going to add some titles in here and text then you can put a divider once
we have the content and we're adding the content we can also switch things out
but just to have it there already prepared for us we'll do this and then
let's use this for images so let's put some images perfect let's add another
section underneath text put a divider spacer another title up here and we'll
go more in depth in the next videos about content and how to structure that
so don't worry about it right now right now we're just framing out our asset and
here at the bottom okay so this is the home page now what we usually do for our
websites and this depends on your competitors so when you do the due
diligence you're going to have the top three websites are ranking and you're
going to see what their website looks look like if your competitor has ten
service pages we definitely want to beat them but on average what we like to do
is create one home page three service pages and a contact page so what you do
after this one is the frame is built out you click on pages and you're actually
going to click on the plus sign right here we are going to make a non
clickable menu this is where you'll have drop down with the services and you're
going to put the page name as services out of it done okay now click I would
actually like to just duplicate the home page because we already have that quote
form it just saves you time so click on home and click on copy and it's just
going to duplicate it so we're going to change the name of it you're going to in
my sample for my client I would like to call this stamped concrete that's one of
the main services and again you want to pick the three service pages to
represent the main most searched three services in that niche in that location
that your client covers okay make sure there's nothing in the SEO settings
always make sure and you're very attentive to details this is very
important when you do things like that okay so the title and the number will
always remain consistent and the same in every page down here the h1 we haven't
even put in so we don't need to worry about the only thing is remember when we
created the quote form in the form name just make sure you switch that I just I
would just put service one oops service one save it and then everything else
can stay the same we should actually add the phone number at the bottom as well
so let's make a separate section right here at the bottom so we don't forget
and drag a title in and we're going to put another the same phone number we're
just going to put it down align it in the center and let's do that on the
homepage as well so right at the bottom after you're done writing all of your
content you're going to have a section that is just having the phone number
xxxx align the center let's create the other two pages and once you're done so
this looks perfect the only thing is we want to make it underneath the service
how you do that see you just see when you screwed it over it gives that gap
right here and boom it's right here so let's just copy this one as well and
make sure that it's underneath there as well we're going to call this concrete
driveway make sure the quote form says s2 so you know this is service page
number two and then we're going to copy it again make our last service page and
again you can go in and add it and make as many as you like this is just the
average of what we usually do I'm going to call this patio and just make sure the
quote form says three and then we're going to add a contact page the contact
page is very simple it's actually going to be so it's not going to be under
so we want home services and home again that is going to be contact contact us
and then you can actually delete every section because the only thing the
contact page is going to have is a big form to fill out for them and then on
the contact page we also add the link to the Google My Business so we definitely
want this phone number down there but you can go ahead and delete the content
and just have the main quote form right here I don't know why did that see
that's why you want to pay attention to you tell sometimes often designer we
believe it we believe in general we have little glitches so you want to make sure
that everything looks how we first set it up on every page
name number and email going to save it see it's already looking different for
some reason so just make sure it all looks the same
save again attention to details is very important when you're building out this
framework so just make sure that everything looks consistent because if
it if it doesn't you know if you have stuff like this coming up to someone
it's going to look not very professional so just touch it up make sure you're
checking every page even if we did duplicate them just double and triple
check on things being very consistent on each page same with the header and you
again you shouldn't have to do this all the time sometimes it does this
see that pretty sure there you go okay service to last service page and we are
almost done building the frame of our asset right here make sure you always
click save as well and then perfect this looks good the only thing that sometimes
we like to do but this is totally optional click on build and sometimes
just to make the quote pop especially if you're using a white background under
the header so just like this one is called we like to use a color block so
just drag this right above the quote okay like that and then you're going to
drag the whole quote form in it like that now it's not going to look like it's
anything but you can actually change that's how you make the quote in a
different color and this sucks in Weebly but you it's you don't only have this
option you can actually put your own colors here and how you do that is I
think if you click here and change color it will give you a color palette okay I
know it's at the bottom but let's say we wanted to make it a nice and bright
yellow a little more orange like that you can copy this code I don't know why
it's not copying it click out of it change color okay I'm just going to write
it down so it's F1 AB 40 okay you click again on the color block and you change
color and you can insert your own color so you don't have to pick out of these
ones one eight be forty click out of it and it will make it that color okay
perfect and it moved the surfaces again
okay perfect and you're going to this to do this for every page again now you're
probably looking at the quote from this is one when you make colors and
adjustments and stuff like that you're going to see well you can't really see
here right and if you click up here in this desktop you can actually see how
the website would look on phone so keep that in mind as well like this looks
gigantic it looks silly on a phone so and the spacer we probably want to remove
because it's a really big gap so click back here and once you we are done
adding the content we're going to do the little touch-ups but just really quick
click on theme this is where you can change the color and the fonts and we
please nice so he actually highlights what things are you see it's going to
highlight that the paragraph title can remain the same the paragraph text we
want to make it black because it's pretty hard to see there you go and then
you can change the font let's try things out okay feel like that's all more
visible and then we are going to delete the spacer again it's totally up to you
just kind of how you see things going and then this we like to do it a
different color and the one above this a little bigger oops make sure you save
save save let's make this a little more yellow and then again this is up to
your preference just can even make it blue okay 40 CDF one see if that looks
better again don't overthink this but you can definitely make smaller
adjustments okay and we are done building the frame